this weekend it's hot out there people
are going to be heading to the shore to
the water oceans lakes and rivers just
looking for some relief from that heat
and while you're there you may run into
another animal that lives there marine
life sightings what they're called
that's an unexpected thrill of the trip
but what happens if you encounter a sick
or injured animal the federal government
believe it or not works with more than
100 organizations all across the country
to respond to those calls for help and
cbs news's michael george recently saw
firsthand how that process works and he
even got to watch the release of some
healthy seals michael good morning tony
good morning now so often beachgoers
walk right up to seal sea lions and sea
turtles with what they think are
harmless intentions maybe they want that
perfect picture or maybe they think the
animal is injured and they can help but
their actions cause more harm than they
realize
during a recent trip to a wildlife rehab
center on new york's long island we met
willow a seven-month-old gray seal pup
she's adorable i see her looking right
at us and she's got these puppy dog eyes
yeah seals are really like dogs we you
know we call these guys kind of like the
german shepherd they have that longer
snout but willow hasn't had an easy life
in may she was struck by a boat leaving
her with a fractured shoulder and deep
cuts on her back we don't want anything
to happen to these guys maxine montello
and her team at the new york marine
rescue center have spent weeks
rehabilitating willow along with cedar
a male seal who was found with a badly
infected flipper these guys can be a
handful very much
volunteers lenore mcginn and lorraine
meshagno are helping nurse willow and
cedar back to health cedar is a chunky
monkey he's cute he comes up he looks at
you he wants more food constantly
willow's kind of quiet the seals will
definitely have their own personalities
unfortunately more animals are ending up
at the rescue center and too often we're
to blame
boats abandoned fishing gear and
pollution are leading to injuries for
seals and sea turtles one of the biggest
threats the garbage we leave when we go
to the beach we see the entanglements
you know with the plastic bags and the
plastic in the waters they wind up in
the ocean
and then the animals unfortunately
suffer because they eat them thinking
their food another growing problem
harassment people want to get close they
want to get that selfie
they want to touch that animal if you do
see them enjoy from afar and even
well-intentioned people who think
they're helping can make things worse
after willow was injured a good
samaritan picked her up and put her in
his truck to drive her to a vet he
wasn't trying to hurt this animal but
picking these animals up is illegal
they're federally protected under the
marine mammal protection act it's easy
to forget willow and cedar are still
wild animals
if you're at the beach and you see a
beached or injured animal marine
wildlife experts suggest calling the
nearest rescue center i will let you
know
as we were shooting our interview a
bystander did just that calling to
report a badly injured sea turtle thanks
to that call the team was able to save
it this is a kemp's ridley sea turtle so
they're one of the most critically
endangered sea turtles so we really
appreciate you guys calling willow and
cedar are healing nicely and they've
both put on 30 pounds now maxine says
it's time for them to go home
yep one two three the pair had their
final checkup they got weighed 38
swabbed to check for diseases
and had their blood drawn going in after
starting the summer in a rehab facility
it was time to return to the wild
cedar went first and seemed all too
grateful to be back in the water
but willow was nervous for a moment it
seemed like she wouldn't go
but eventually
that moment when they went back into the
water is that what this is all about for
you yeah this is the best part of the
job all our hard work paid off it's our
goal to put them back into the wild to
return them home
so the big takeaway here we share our
beaches with these animals so if we love
them that means we need to resist the
urge to take that selfie and keep our
distance federal law actually says we're
supposed to stay 150 feet away from them
okay some people will do anything though
just to get the shot you have to realize
the consequences of what you're doing
you can do it but you need to stay
really far away in fact they say if you
can hold your thumb up and you can still
see the seal that means you're way too
close so call the professionals first
and then get a selfie after that exactly
so the professionals are you just kind
of google marine rescue in your area and
you'll get a phone number yeah in any
beach community there's a marine rescue
there you've got to look that up and
they know what to do they're trained and
they'll be able to handle that how about
these people in texas apparently riding
a dolphin and the dolphin dies come on
come on michael thank you so much